let me get the reaction here of Anthony
pompliano founder of pump Investments
and an early Bitcoin investor we would
call you an early adopter Anthony do you
think that the SEC will take another
stab will you know try to take down
grayscale and ETF and take another stab
at the Apple so to speak
yeah so one of the things I think is
really interesting here is this is the
beauty of America is we have Market
participants and Regulators going into
court laying out their best argument and
the courts are deciding who they
actually put more weight behind in that
decision and so one of the things that I
think is really important is that the
SEC obviously has a choice to make now
no one knows what they're going to do
but I do think that if we go back two
years and we look at when it was just
grayscale or it was just kind of
fly-by-night organizations who had ETF
applications in that's very different
than today where we now have BlackRock
Fidelity Arc invest Etc and so I do
think that an idea's Time Has Come a
Bitcoin spot ETF is likely to be
approved at some point in the next 12 to
18 months when it happens how it happens
no one knows but I do think that the
American court system this is the beauty
of this country and if we want to
continue to embrace the entrepreneurial
DNA of the country while also having a
fair Financial Market that protects
investors this is a perfect example of
how we can do that and allow Market
participants and Regulators to lay out
their arguments in front of those course
do you think that this momentum changes
at all the liquidity in the crypto
Market
yeah look Bitcoin is in a really really
interesting point about 70 percent of
the Bitcoin that's in circulation today
is being held by people who are not
selling they've been holding this
Bitcoin for over a year despite all of
the volatility and so whenever you have
something like a Bitcoin spot ETF that's
kind of on Deck it's next up and if it
does get approved that will lead to a
very significant increase in demand
specifically from institutions remember
Bitcoin has been adopted by individuals
in retail first if they wanted to buy
Bitcoin they'd gone and signed up for a
crypto exchange and they've bought
Bitcoin but now we are seeing
institutions knocking at the door and so
that's a huge wave of demand but don't
forget we're less than one year away
from the Bitcoin having as well which is
a supply shock and so if you go back to
2020 we've seen this Playbook before we
had a supply shock in the having we had
a demand shot coming from all the money
printing from the government now what
we're seeing is the supply shock coming
from the having within the next 12
months and we're seeing a potential
demand shot coming from these ETF
applications last time we went up
hundreds of percent in price and if we
get both of these events to occur within
a 12-month period I think that we will
see a very big price appreciation at
this point once again doesn't matter who
gets to Market first
that's the big question uh it does
matter who is there first we have seen
time and time again from the ETF
applications whoever is first to Market
they tend to suck up all of the assets
what I think will be very interesting I
don't know if this is going to happen
but it would be interesting to see the
SEC approve multiple issuers all at the
same time and kind of let the market
figure it out rather than the SEC play
referee and decide who goes first who
goes second instead if they just said
look we're gonna let you guys all into
the market and then let you all figure
out who gets the assets I think that may
be something that would be interesting I
can see it now it's like it's like a
racehorse you line them all up and then
count it down and just open the gates
and let them run the race all right Mr
pompliano thank you for your time sir
yeah sure thing